oder was geht hier ist ein kran ii und
ich bin gerade von venedig nach hause
gekommen
wir haben jetzt kurz vor 8 und wir sind
den ganzen tag umgeguckt irgendwie seit
elf uhr morgens sollen dementsprechend
bin ich erst mal fertig und zweitens
habe ich kein video gemacht und da
gestern auch schon 1 kam dachte ich mir
für die leute die jetzt nicht auf
twitter oder sowas aktiv sind
dieses kurze abgeschätzt hält dieses
kurzen update das heute auch noch mal
kein video kommt sorry dafür liegt aber
daran gestern war es weil ich den ganzen
tag unterwegs war und nicht
vorproduziert hatte ich auch muss ein
zwei tage ohne film in venedig haben
wollte und auf jeden fall ihr wisst
bescheid
ich hoffe mal das nicht allzu übel und
dann war's das mit diesem update auch
schon länger nicht mehr
jetzt quatsche ich nirgends rum und
tanze damit einem nein mach ich nicht
warum seine minuten waren okay macht's
gut